-Tracy Morgan!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Tracy. Tracy. Tracy.
Always such a joy.
-That was a lot of love, man.
-I feel like a magical black
dude.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I feel magical.
I feel like the black dude
from "Green Mile."
-You feel like that?
-I could just touch a white dude
and feel his senses.
-A healing hand? Oh, my gosh.
My cold just left.
-Cure your syphilis. Yeah.
-Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
There go the bugs.
You're turning 50 on Saturday.
-Yeah. I'm 50. Yeah.
-Happy birthday, man.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm joining the 5-0 club, dog.
How old are you? You young.
-44. 44.
-You young.
-Yeah.
-You got another four more years
before you suffer from E.D.
-What?
[ Laughter ]
-Better start taking them
blue pills.
-Yeah, yeah.
So, you had that happen
to you at 48?
-No.
-Okay, gotcha.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, that's your ---
that's your analysis of me.
-I'm still making babies.
-Oh, yeah. That's right.
You got a 5-year-old.
-Yeah, she's 5, man. Yeah.
She's 5 going on 50.
-Uh-huh.
I see her teeth --
the first tooth came out.
-She lost a tooth.
-Yeah.
And I put a dollar
under her pillow.
-That's very nice.
-And she complained
the next morning.
-what?
-She said, "My daddy got hit
by a Walmart truck,
and this all I get?
[ Laughter ]
Where's my Birkin bag?"
-She wanted a Birkin bag.
-She want a Hermes bag.
-What'd she do for Halloween?
How was your Halloween?
-Oh, man. I don't know, man.
These kids today,
they crazy, man.
A kid knocked on my door
for candy. Right?
And he was supposed to be
a ghost and his sheet was black.
-Uh-huh.
-I said,
"What you supposed to be?"
He said, "I'm a ghost."
I said, "Why your sheet black?"
He said, "I'm keeping it real."
[ Laughter ]
Those holidays, man.
-Thanksgiving is coming up.
You got plans?
-Thanksgiving.
Yeah, Thanksgiving coming up.
Yeah, we plan --
I plan on eating.
-Okay, that's good.
[ Laughter ]
-That's it.
That's all I'm gonna do, eat.
I'm not saying grace this year.
Last year,
my grandmother slipped up
and let my uncle say grace.
He just did 25 years in prison.
-Okay.
-So, he said grace
like he was still in prison.
It's institutionalized.
-What does grace in prison
sound like?
-He just said,
"Who's that dude over there?"
I said, "that's my uncle.
Your brother.
You don't cut meat with a shank.
[ Laughter ]
Take the razor blade
out your mouth!"
[ Laughter ]
-Christmas.
-What do you for Christmas?
-I don't lie to my kids. Okay?
That's what I don't do.
-You don't lie?
-No.
Ain't no fat, jolly white dude
bring you nothing!
[ Laughter ]
You know what your mother
had to do for you
to get that Easy-Bake Oven?
[ Laughter ]
You better play with that toy
until you're 40.
[ Laughter ]
-You live in New Jersey now.
Correct?
-Yeah, why?
-Nice neighborhood?
-Anybody asking about it?
-What?
-The government asking you about
it?
-No.
-Government always on my ass
around tax time.
-Do you know your neighbors?
-Oh, man.
I live in a very affluent
neighborhood.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
I live in Alpine, New Jersey.
My neighbor --
one of my neighbors
is the CEO of Pepsi.
-Wow.
-CEO of Pepsi.
When we moved in, she came over
with a gift basket.
I was like, "Oh, wow.
This is beautiful.
Thank you for welcoming me
and my family
into your neighborhood."
And she was warm and kind,
and I let her know it would be
an honor for me to one day
get hit by one of your trucks.
-Wow, that's --
[ Laughter ]
-I did. I did.
[ Applause ]
I did. Be an honor.
It would be an honor.
-Hey, your show "The Last O.G."
coming back for a second season.
A fantastic show.
Congratulations.
-I love the work we did.
Thank you.
That's ripped
right from my life.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ripped right from my life.
-Season two spends a lot of time
dealing with gentrification.
-Yeah.
-Is that something that
you remember happening
in your neighborhood?
-Nah. When i was coming up
in the neighborhood,
that wasn't happening.
-Okay.
-You know? It's different now.
White people moving in.
We moving out.
The other day, I was in Harlem,
and I seen a white family
going down the street
pushing a stroller whistling.
I'm black and I was scared
to death to grow up there.
[ Laughter ]
And plus, I don't even know
how to whistle.
[ Laughter ]
Black people, we just
ain't happy enough to whistle.
We've ain't never been
happy enough. To whistle.
-You're married, obviously.
You have a beautiful wife.
-Uh-huh, my wife is a dime.
-Yeah.
-You see, you go on Instagram,
you see my wife is beautiful.
She biracial.
-Your wife is biracial.
-Yeah. She's a dime.
She ain't a nickel
and five pennies.
-Uh-huh.
-She ain't ten pennies.
She's a dime.
-Gotcha.
-Biracial. Oh, man. You know
my first words when I met her?
-What was that?
-You're going to get pregnant.
-Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-You're going to get pregnant.
-Now...
-I tell you the truth, man.
You know --- you know me, man.
I'm old school.
I don't pull out.
[ Laughter ]
-I --
-I'm old school, B.
I'm like prison.
When I come in, I come in.
[ Laughter ]
I don't believe it
when -- No! No!
I don't believe in when --
I don't believe in wearing
no condoms on the first date.
[ Laughter ]
If you ain't willing
to die for it,
you really didn't want it.
[ Laughter ]
My wife is half-white
and half-black.
So, before we make love,
I take a knee.
Now, just to let the white side
of her know black lives matter.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Black lives matter.
[ Laughter ]
Play no games.
That's my baby girl.
I love my wife.
I love you, Megan.
-That's very sweet.